I've been talking for a while about a
way that elected officials really
Republicans and Trump could damage the
Affordable Care Act without repealing
the Affordable Care Act and that is by
sabotaging it or sabotaging it to quote
William Shatner without actually
repealing it merely by defunding it okay
Donald Trump has now taken some steps to
do exactly this just before this recent
weekend Donald Trump has decided he's
going to get rid of the subsidies to
health insurers for low-income people to
help them pay for health insurance right
this will be one of those situations
that will not change the law but it will
change the ability for the government to
help people pay for insurance Donald
Trump is also going to allow for even
cheaper policies that will have very few
benefits and few customer protections
another way that you are going to damage
the end consumer of health insurance and
this is so funny actually
there's this guy in the video if you're
watching guy with the mustache and the
glasses over Trump's right shoulder I
know that guy that's Dave Ratner he's
the owner of this retail chain called
Dave's soda and pet city out in Western
Massachusetts when I worked at Circuit
City I sold that guy some computers he
was not known as a right-winger in
western Massachusetts and he showed up
behind Trump when Trump was signing some
of this some of this nonsense and he is
getting crushed because Western
Massachusetts is so liberal and people
are furious that Dave Ratner is there
defending Trump signing of a bill that
is going to be terrible for people and
Dave Ratner now has issued some major
apology saying I'm not there because I
support Trump I've always wanted
employers to be able to buy insurance
across state lines or something I'm not
a bad guy and his business now is
actually significantly in danger I would
say not of going out of business but of
being damaged in terms of profitability
anyway that's Dave Ratner back to the
Obamacare stuff the idea here is what
the Affordable Care Act will stay but
premiums are going to increase
because now that the insurers are no
longer going to get government subsidies
they are going to have to make up for
that lost revenue by charging people
more for insurance it's very very
straightforward insurers are realizing
that this is not going to be good for
them because when they do have to raise
premiums they're going to lose some
customers right and they were expecting
nine billion dollars in the coming year
they had nearly a hundred billion coming
to them in the coming decade that they
are now not going to get this is
spiteful disgusting vile and it's an
attempt to score political points by
hurting people and lots of those people
are Trump voters President Obama warned
us about this others during the end of
the Obama administration warned us you
know without repealing Obama care you
could defund aspects of it and I've been
talking about it for months but here's
the kicker Trump does this and it
crashes health insurance stock prices
now I'm not taking a position on whether
that's good or bad I've said before if
we had single-payer health care it would
probably also be bad for health
insurance companies and their share
value but this announcement was bad for
health insurance stocks and Trump goes
on Twitter and brags about it
Trump took to Twitter over the weekend
and said health insurance stocks which
have gone through the roof during the
Obamacare years plunged yesterday after
I ended their democratic Democrats
windfall number one days ago Donald
Trump was taking credit for the massive
stock market rally that we've seen
during the first seven eight months of
the Trump administration now Trump is
cheering that his actions have crashed
the stocks the stock prices of health
insurance companies from one day to the
next Trump has gone from stocks are
doing great and it's because of me two
stocks have plunged and it's because of
me and somehow both are good well which
is it both can't possibly be true but my
bigger question to Donny boy is if
you're okay with crashing health
insurance stocks if you're doing
something you feel is good for people
with health care why not just do
single-payer that's what would be the
best for people and it would also be bad
for health insurance stocks and you can
brag about
the way you're doing now on Twitter I
don't understand the logic behind this
and it's probably because there is no
logic what I want to touch on is how
this will impact you there's basically
two parts here this is part of the
cost-sharing reduction program part one
is that insurance companies have to give
people on silver plans whose incomes are
under two hundred and fifty percent of
the poverty line lower deductibles and
co-payments that doesn't change with
what Donald Trump is signed part two is
that there are budget items that give
insurers money to reimburse people or
rather give insurer's money to reinforce
them for having lower deductibles to
low-income people that's the part that
Trump is crushing part two part one is
not going to be touched how much money
could you make shorting stocks if you
knew ahead of time what stunts Donald
Trump had planned and shorting stocks is
basically it's a way to you're basically
borrowing stocks with the idea that the
price is going to decrease and you can
make money off of the decrease of the
value of a stock imagine if Vlad
Vladimir Putin who according to some
including Fareed Zakaria is by far the
richest person on the planet even though
he does a good job of hiding his wealth
imagine if Vlad knew what stunts Trump
was planning a lot of money that could
be made about on that maybe we'll learn
about that someday the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad